ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
l tijera
que para muchos debería estar ciego
inválida
o inclusive muerto
no me lo creerían
durante 12 años de mi vida fui boxeador
inclusive llegué a pertenecer al comité
olímpico mexicano pero el sueño de ir a
unos juegos olímpicos se vio esfumado
por algo llamado corrupción a partir de
ese momento decidí tomar el papel de
víctima total es más cómodo no
el 31 de marzo de 2007 me casé y un mes
después mi esposa me dio la noticia de
que íbamos a ser papás
eso solo representaba una preocupación
para mí
dios el universo como lo quieres llamar
es tan buen maestro que te envían las
pruebas necesarias para aprender no
puedes evolucionar hasta no aprobar tu
pasado
tres meses después de la boda un
diamante si lo podía ver bien
me detectaron una condición llamada
queratocono de córnea prácticamente me
restaban no más de tres meses de vista
mi mejor opción era un tratamiento
temporal y esperar un trasplante de
córnea mínimo dos años invidente eso un
milagro
yo opté por la segunda opción mi meta
era poder ver no perderme la oportunidad
de que mis ojos conocieran a mi hijo
entonces nos enteramos de un
procedimiento sumamente doloroso llamado
cross linking que promete curarme no me
lo pensé me sometí a él y la
cicatrización duró un mes durante el
cual estuve ciego
a veces podría dormir solo gracias a la
morfina la mayoría del tiempo deseaba la
muerte por el dolor intenso
y cuando creíamos que ya todo marcharía
mejor ocurrió lo impensable casi al
final de mi recuperación aún con los
ojos vendados sufrió un accidente
me separé de mi esposa por unos segundos
tropecé y que hay de casi 2 metros de
altura
partiendo de la rodilla
sí exacto
primero ciego ahora cojo y mi esposa
embarazada que les puedo decir
y me preguntaba lo que todos nos
preguntamos cuando pasamos por una
tragedia porque a mí
es que no quería darme cuenta que tenía
todo lo necesario para ser feliz una
esposa y un bebé
minutos antes de entrar a la cirugía
ahora de la rodilla
mi esposa un abrazo
puso su vientre mi rostro
y entonces ocurrió
el bebé dio su primera patada justo en
mi cara
por fin le entendí
esa patada es de la voluntad que
necesitaba para salir adelante
ahora mi meta era estar de pie cuando mi
hijo naciera y mi rehabilitación sería
el ciclismo así que decidí decidí
hacerlo de forma competitiva para mí era
vital darle un ejemplo a mi esposa ya mi
hijo de lo que alguna vez represente
como atleta cuánta gente no se jacta de
sus glorias pasadas y nunca las llevan
al presente para mí esa frase de yo fui
es igual ya no soy y eso era lo que no
quería demostrar
para este punto de mi vida
pensé pensábamos que ya la había librado
sin embargo
en un entrenamiento de ciclismo en un
parque
un niño es un triciclo se me atravesó
y yo tuve que tomar una decisión
arrollarlo o estrellarse contra un poste
y que creen
desperté en el hospital
con una costilla rota más de 30 puntadas
en diferentes partes del cuerpo
trombosis en ambas piernas y una lesión
en los discos de la columna que se fue
agravando con los días
primero deje de sentir la pierna
izquierda
luego la pierna derecha hasta el punto
que ya no pude caminar
exacto
no daba a una
nadie quiere operarme era tan riesgoso
que decían que mi mejor opción era una
silla de ruedas
yo no podría aceptar eso no ahora que
estaba tan cerca de lograrlo mi única
opción era un tratamiento de
infiltración de ozono directo a la
columna pero más importante acompañado
de una terapia al ver que el tratamiento
duraría dos años
solo quería no tenía ese tiempo mi hijo
ya empezaba a gatear así que me propuse
un nuevo reto aprender a caminar de la
mano de mi hijo
tenía que verme de pie
si me mandaban 30 minutos en la alberca
no hacía una hora si me mandaban una
hora
yo hacía dos la natación me devolvió en
un año no solamente la sensibilidad en
las piernas sino una segunda oportunidad
de vida
y bueno pues las largas horas de
entrenamiento le llamaron la atención a
varias entrenadores que me acercaron a
un deporte llamado nado en aguas
abiertas
fue entonces cuando me encontró el canal
de la mancha el reto deportivo más
peligroso del mundo más gente ha
conquistado el everest que los que han
logrado el canal de la mancha
las razones mareas altas corrientes
agresivas la sal que te carcome una
larga distancia por recorrer pero más
importante el frío extremo que te mata
lentamente
las reglas dicen que no puedes utilizar
ningún tipo de protección contra el frío
una vez que inicias no puedes parar
y no puedes ser tocado ni tocar a nadie
eres solo tú y el mar
con el tiempo mis tiempos como nadador
fueron suficientes para cruzarlo pero no
le ve sentido a arriesgarme a hacerlo
solamente por el reconocimiento propio
así que decidí hacer un acto de
agradecimiento a la vida tenía tanto por
agradecer
fue entonces cuando encontré a una nueva
esperanza asociación que se encarga de
apoyar a niños de bajos con unos
recursos que sufren de cáncer desde al
hospedaje alimento ropa pero lo más
importante les dan el medicamento
necesario para salir adelante no es
justo que la vida dependa de tu
capacidad económica para curarte tenía
que hacer algo al respecto así que me
propuse cruzar a nado el canal de la
mancha para recaudar un millón de pesos
para el banco de medicinas oncológicas
de una nueva esperanza
mi sueño era y seguirá siendo combatir
el cáncer infantil que la voluntad de
esos niños sea un ejemplo para mí
el 22 de septiembre
y va a comenzar el cruce pero antes nos
mandó a llamar el observador quién es el
que da fe y legalidad del cruce y me
dijo
mira cristiano no quiero que nadie se
canal de la mancha
y dije por qué
porque eres mexicano y no lo vas a
lograr
me enseñó una pila de currículums que
más bien eran tesis
de todos los nadadores que lo habían
intentado y luego
me enseñó el mío
un folder con dos hojas
y además ya saben como en la escuela
margen reducido el título en grande
letra 16 doble 2.5 espacio
pero no podía negarme en nada por mis
tiempos en el último año y me dijo
los mexicanos estadísticamente fallan
renuncia ahora o muere mañana
y ahí sí me enoje
y le dije en esas hojas solo vas a
encontrar tinta
hay algo que no puedes medir ahí hay
algo que no vas a encontrar ahí la
voluntad del mexicano y me pare me fui
ahora sí el 22 de septiembre de 2013
comenzó el cruce a nado del canal de la
mancha mi maestría del dolor
el agua estaba helada quemaban a entrar
a las 8 horas el tendón del bíceps
izquierdo se desgarró
a las 10 horas el tendón del manguito
rotador también
en ese momento me paran y me dicen que
ya me van a sacar porque no había
avanzado nada en las últimas dos horas
de nado avanzaba 300 metros pero sería
200 avanzaba 200 reto sería 100 mi coach
me dice que la única opción era nadar a
en sprint a toda velocidad y está esta
sería la señal y le pregunté coach
cuánto va a durar el sprint lo que tenga
que durar
y esta señal está señala vi durante
cinco malditas horas
cuando tu sueño es verdadero el tiempo
debe ser atemporal
pero a las 15 horas de nado continuo
mi cuerpo estaba despedazado
y me empieza a morir
me duele el corazón me verán los
pulmones me quedaba dormido tragaba
muchísima agua era de noche a mitad del
mar abierto tenía hipotermia la
temperatura del agua bajó aún más
tenía miedo mucho miedo
y aunque me ayudaba a ver en lo alto del
barco ondear la bandera de un lado la de
mi país y del otro lado la de una nueva
esperanza
la verdad es que ya nada me mantenía a
flote
cuando vi que era inevitable mi muerte
decidí cerrar los ojos y nadar
nada hasta que mi vida terminara
de repente los abro
y veo a nivel de mar la cara de mis
hijos y ahí sí dije ya valió me morí
pero no era mi esposa que se había
colgado con el ipad y una imagen de mis
hijos se ha colgado del barco para que
yo los pudiera ver cada vez que salía
respirar
verlos a los 3
tan cerca de mí en ese momento
me dio la fuerza necesaria para terminar
y hamás desde ese día hasta la fecha he
vuelto a repetir esa frase
ya no puedo
17 horas con 38 minutos y 62 kilómetros
después
tocamos la costa de francia
[Aplausos]
pero la pesadilla del canal de la mancha
aún no terminada
cuando estaba aún en el agua nadando
sentí una ámpula en la garganta que no
me dejaba respirar así que decidí
arrancármela pero no funcionó y cuando
me subieron al barco me empieza a
asfixiar
porque resulta que lo que trate de
arrancarme fue la campanilla
y ésta se había inflamado tanto que no
me dejaba respirar
me empecé a ahogar en el barco
el doctor no estaba el helicóptero de
rescate nunca llegó y mi esposa tuvo que
tomar las riendas de la situación habló
a méxico le dijeron quedarme y sobre la
piel congelada me inyecto pero no
funcionaba el medicamento yo me estaba
muriendo
entonces ocurrió
mi esposa me abrazo por detrás puso sus
manos en mi pecho
y me obligó a respirar empujando mi idea
fragma
ese día
de esa mujer una vez más le salvaba la
vida
[Aplausos]
pero importante es que con este hecho
logramos recaudar un millón de pesos
para el banco de medicinas oncológicas
de una nueva esperanza
[Aplausos]
y canal de la mancha le dejó muchas
secuelas la peor de todas fue un daño en
los pulmones le provocó una
bronconeumonía llenando mis pulmones de
agua
los doctores decían tú ya no vas a poder
volver a nadar se acabó la natación para
ti
yo no podía aceptar eso
teníamos muchos niños por apoyar así que
con medicamento hierbas y mucha voluntad
de mi esposa
un año después me dieron de alta y
estaba listo para el siguiente reto el
canal de catalina el canal de catalina
es el lado entre la isla de santa
catalina california y la costa de
california prácticamente es un
copy-paste del canal de la mancha sólo
que con aguas menos frías pero con un
plus infestado por tiburones
el 29 de septiembre de 2015 comenzó el
cruce a nado del canal y catalina con
olas de hasta 4 metros de altura
me sentía tan fuerte físicamente que
descuide mi fortaleza mental
graves más grave error
eran las cuatro la mañana estaba nadando
y de repente vio pasar por debajo de mí
algo
algo grande
segundos después lo vuelvo a ver
y es cuando me doy cuenta que es un
tiburón
empezó a rondar me de círculos
y de repente lo deje de ver
cuando me doy cuenta lo traigo a un lado
siguiendo por detrás el kayakista que me
escoltaba
su masa de agua
me movía
ese día conocí el verdadero significado
de la palabra pavor
y dije dios si existe este es un buen
momento para demostrarlo
saben algo
cuando pierdes el control de la
situación tienes dos opciones dejar que
las circunstancias y el miedo te demoren
o seguir nadando y seguir nadando con la
esperanza de llegar al otro lado ese día
aprendí que no hay forma de llegar al
otro lado sin ayuda
por eso cuando creíamos que todo iba a
terminar mal
de repente escucho en el agua algo que
solo yo podría escuchar
el canto de los delfines
un grupo grande de delfines pasaron por
debajo de mí rápido alentando al tiburón
y dos de los delfines nos acompañaron
hasta el final del trayecto
13 horas con 59 minutos
y casi 40 kilómetros de nado continuo
después
un sueño mexicano
toco la costa de eeuu
[Aplausos]
este año me propongo terminan la triple
corona de aguas abiertas al nadar la
vuelta a manhattan es un reto complicado
por las aguas heladas las corrientes
pero sobre todo porque es a contratiempo
un sprint de 9 horas
el 20 de agosto de este año 2017 me voy
a convertir en el octavo mexicano en
completar la triple corona pero el
primero en hacerlo por una causa
puramente altruista y este último es lo
más importante
recaudar un millón de pesos más para el
banco de medicinas oncológicas de una
nueva esperanza
si le dijera
y no estoy ciego
el inválido
ni mucho menos muerto
por algo que ustedes y yo tenemos
no me lo creerían
voluntad
con gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]